this is a story about how I followed my
stolen iPhone across the world became a
celebrity in China and found a friend
for life okay so this story begins long
long ago in 2014 in the East Village
a lot of time when we finish work we get
drinks and so we get to that bar and
we're having drinks we're getting a
little drunk
and I put my phone down go on talking to
my friends look back and my phone's gone
so I do what anyone else does in that
situation I freak the [ __ ] out make
everyone get up empty their pockets look
in their coats my phone it had to be
somewhere I have my friend call my phone
and it goes straight to voicemail that
phone was gone forever so then the next
day I go out buy a new cell phone and
think okay that's it
the phone is done let's move on now but
then things got really strange and kind
of creepy
so I'm sitting on my couch a few months
later and I see all of these pictures
that I didn't take and then there were
like 30 selfies of this man posing very
seriously with an orange tree right away
the first thought is my phone got hacked
most normal people in this position
would probably do something about their
phone but for some reason I didn't but
then one day I was talking to this one
friend and she said has your phone been
stolen lately and I said yeah a couple
months ago and she goes you know most
stolen iPhones end up in China and so I
was like my phone must have been in
China
so what happened was I never killed that
iPhone and my iCloud was still logged
into that phone so basically it was
sending me all of the pictures that were
being taken on that phone to my new
phone the Apple guy is like okay well do
you want to kill that phone and I'm like
I guess it's been kind of fun of having
these pictures coming all the time but
it's also kind of creepy knowing that my
phone is in China and it's like logged
into this guy's account and I'm getting
all of his pictures so I kill it and I
ended up writing a story for BuzzFeed
called who is this man and wires picture
showing up on my phone I go to bed that
night thinking okay now the story is
definitely over
that's when totally hits the fan I wake
up the next morning and I go on my
computer and the first thing I'm going
to tweet and I look at my mentions and
it's from a bunch of little eggs if you
use Twitter you know that it means that
someone who's just signed up for an
account and it's hundreds of tweets of
people telling me hey Matt we're trying
to help you find an orange guy you guys
are long-lost brothers you guys need to
meet and then they start sending me
screenshots I was going viral on Weibo
which is basically Chinese Twitter it's
like the top 10 trending topics and it's
all in Chinese like 2 through 10 and
then number 1 is my name Mets to puro so
I go into work and I end up joining
Weibo and instantly I get hundreds of
thousands of followers and they're
telling me okay we're gonna find this
guy you guys are meant to be this is the
greatest love story that we've ever
heard of all time and I'm like
and sure enough they find this guy who
at this time they had given the nickname
brother or brother once joins Chinese
Twitter we start talking on Chinese
Twitter it's like a public social media
romance or sending each other pictures
and videos every day and then he invites
me to go to China two more days
so I'm telling my boss is like you guys
don't even understand what's happening
there's this whole other world out there
Chinese social media and I'm getting
thousands of comments on pictures of me
holding oranges that I'm posting on the
social media and I'm telling my bosses
you don't understand I need to go to
China this is like a very big meme there
and it this I have to go so that night I
get a message and it says okay Matt to
China is the subject line and it's like
okay this is happening I'm actually
gonna go to China and I'm gonna meet
this guy brother one if you've ever
misplaced your cell phone you know how
it often turns up in the last place you
look little over a year ago senior
editor and BuzzFeed named Matt Stara
left his iPhone at a bar in New York
City that last place turned out to be 79
hundred miles away in China
I'm a ducati through Ahmad fathanah this
man
so I'm on my way to China it takes me 20
hours to get there I'm on my connecting
flight to Majo and I'm sitting in my
seat and this teenager comes up to me
and she starts freaking out and she's
like oh my god I can't believe it are
you mad this is so crazy I can't believe
the fate I meant to meet you on this
plane and I'm like this is never
happened to me before I can't believe
that this girl recognises Who I am and
it was like my first touch with fame
until I got off the plane
[Music]
and so we go down the escalator and
that's when I see a huge crowd of people
I feel like Britney Spears there
paparazzi everywhere and they were there
for me so I get my bag and I go through
and then there he is
brother orange and all of these cameras
just swarm us and brother orange has
this huge bouquet of flowers and the
first thing he goes he goes why China
yeah thank you thank you so and then the
news people started screaming at me I
don't speak Chinese
I know one thing so I go Nihao Nihao me
how just over and over because I don't
know what to do this is never happening
before and I should have learned some
Chinese but I didn't have time it all
happened so quickly
brother orange pulls out my cell phone
the one that got stolen and he hands it
to me and so I go what happened to this
phone how did you get it and so
obviously he didn't come to the US and
steal it he got it from his cousin who
owns a used cell phone shop a few hours
away from him
still recognize it right it is so weird
to see it was such a long time ago we
leave the airport and we're being
hounded by the paparazzi they're yelling
at us they're chasing us and we go up to
this SUV that's so crazy that is so nice
and that this is your Chinese name you
know they go so deep wait thank O'Neal
or something
see my pictures on but he deleted them
later
so we're driving an hour to brother
Wanda's hometown and I don't know if
you've ever been photographed or taken
video by 30 people while you're eating
but that's what happened to me next
first of all I'm not very good at using
chopsticks so it's broadcast in to all
of China and just how awful I am at this
is the most embarrassing thing we check
in the hotel I go up to my room and I'm
just like what is going on today is
literally the first day of all of this
we're going for a ceremony but I don't
really know what this ceremony means
lassen he was having that firecrackers
and banging drums which I'm like all
right it sounds cool
[Music]
so the paparazzi is all there and we eat
and we plant an orange tree to signify
our Chinese and American friendship so
this begins this week of absolute
insanity of us being followed by the
paparazzi constantly we're taking mud
baths together and let me tell you
there's nothing more awkward than a
bunch of people you're wearing a little
hair net and you're with some guy that
you've never met before and he's pouring
it all over you while everyone's taking
pictures it's the most awkward thing
that I've ever done we have our own
press conference people are like I want
to sing for you will you dance for me
we're going out to eat people are
putting liquor bottles in front of me
taking pictures of it as if I'm
endorsing it people were coming up to me
handing me their babies asking me to
take pictures with their babies let me
just remind you that this is all because
I lost my cell phone that any of this is
happening everywhere we go there's just
people asking they take our pictures are
people asking us for autographs and
we're one of these T fields were writing
bicycles together we're eating and
eating and eating I've never eaten so
much in my life the day is just
completely packed full of just craziness
until the last day the last day is when
kind of everything changed brother
orange had had enough of the media
circus and he really just wanted to show
me his restaurant his home his parents
home and just the things that he really
cares about in majo and so that day he
made everyone go away and so we went to
his childhood home we climbed his
childhood tree
and we held a ceremony for his ancestors
one of the things that I learned along
this way is that the Chinese have this
like very strong belief in fate and
destiny my phone could have ended up
with a billion people in China but
without it being him and without me
having this platform of buzzfeed nothing
would have ever happened and my phone
would have just been another oh that
sucks your phone got stolen story
everyone says to me well how can you be
friends with someone if you don't speak
the same language and the first thing I
say to them is what is friendship
friendship is just a series of shared
experiences and me and brother orange
had the craziest experience ever you
can't even make it up it's like
Cinderella
on speed except the glass slipper is an
iPhone and it's a fairytale it's
literally a love story and then the trip
is over so we go to the airport and it's
just like in the movies and he walks me
right up to the gate and we have our
arms around each other and we say
goodbye and he's just standing there as
I go through security waving bye bye bye
bye bye he turned the corner he's still
there just waving goodbye
hmm
that's crazy I've lived in this world
for the past week and uh I don't want I
don't want to leave this world it's such
a I don't I I want this world to go on
and so then I think the story is over
from there
but as I've learned throughout this
whole experience nothing is ever over
woman since I see I lose you so then
brother orange comes to the u.s. please
welcome
Matt's Tepera all the way from China
brother orange Mian bro go on Ellen we
take a road trip to Las Vegas we meet
Britney Spears he flies to New York I
basically do all the things that he did
for me in China but to him so he meets
my family
he meets everyone I work with we throw a
big party here at work so then it's time
for bro to leave but this time unlike
the other times before I know not to
assume that this is the end of the story
because this is a story that just won't
ever die and it hasn't died my life has
not been the same ever since I talked to
bro almost every day I legitimately have
a whole other family in China if you if
you said at the beginning of this that I
would be crying at the end Oh at the end
of this I would think that you were
insane
[Music]
it's so surreal this whole thing has
been it's really if it sounds almost
cliche and for like I'm forcing this but
I really feel like I understand how how
the Chinese believe in fate and destiny
after this I really feel like how could
this not be fate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you